well the company behind the very popular
Las Vegas show absinthe has bought a
California town right to ourselves yes
beagle world says it shows the community
of nipton to expand and turn it into a
living town and artistic Oasis it's an
hour Southwest from our area 20 minutes
from Primm
so Joshua peguero stopped by nipton
today and spoke to his brand new owner
speaker World bought the town last year
after the property had been sitting
empty for several years staff is working
to clear debris and turn empty lots into
a circus Village
Spiegel world is aiming to use nipton as
a place where its artists can recharge
and create new acts everything we do on
the Strip whether it's absent at
Caesar's Palace OPM at Cosmopolitan or
Atomic Saloon at Venetian needs constant
development we're always looking at
building big new acts Ross wallison and
Rosario extraordinaire says the air
reminds him of his native Australia
mittens a very unusual area in that it's
in the middle of the Mojave Desert but
it's an oasis Roxanne Lang and her late
husband Jerry Freeman previously owned
the town before Spiegel World bought it
for nearly three million dollars laying
so nibbed into a cannabis company they
wanted to convert nipton into a
marijuana retreat but that didn't work
out speaker World plans to beautify the
town just making the trying to return
the desert back to what it was
um but then in much we start work we've
got our first Workshop production out
there we'll be out there for two weeks
but nebton has between 15 to 20
residents much of the businesses
including the Hotel California are
closed but speaker world has plans to
reopen it and convert another of the
buildings into a restaurant Spiegel
world is also planning to do a project
here that's inspired by the arrival of
Formula One racing to Las Vegas
reporting in nipton Joshua peguero eight
news now
as you mentioned Spiegel World hoping to
be fully done with the transformation in
nipton by end of year in time for
formula one they're opening but the
company adds it also won't Rush opening
the town to the public